so when I said the story about Disney
yes guy Kevin sends me this picture he
says we just got off a Disney cruise and
he says on the cruise this is one of the
guys that was telling the story to the
kids I said okay what's wrong with the
picture he's telling a nice story he
says look at what he's wearing shoes I'm
like What's He wearing Jacob can you
zoom in can you zoom in he's wearing
high heels talking to to kids yeah okay
so look
this is going to confuse parents what
parents are going to say I'm sorry
Disney I'm just not taking my kids to
the cruise period there's going to be a
lot of parents that don't want to answer
unnecessary questions yet to an
eight-year-old kid it's too early to
have those types of conversations when
you get things like this this is not
controversial this is the average parent
doesn't want to talk about you know a
lot of different topics that they don't
want to talk to them about this being
one of them so if Disney thinks this is
okay to say what's wrong with that let
them do that kind of things you again
Disney don't understand who your
customers and two you have lost control
of your company your brand what it stood
for you have fully lost control and it's
it's to the point where there are
walking on eggshells wondering what they
need to do to turn the company around
one of the best things we witnessed
during covet one of the best things we
witnessed during covid was a case study
of Disney one was Disneyland the other
one was Disney World right California
University of Florida that was great one
was Disneyland hey you know we're gonna
do this and we're gonna do that and
we're gonna shut and Disney was like nah
California Calif because remember
Bob biker was sitting on the board with
gamma Newsom to help going through this
process and in California shuts down the
park and then Bob Iger resigns from
Gavin newsom's Camp says listen man I
don't want to help you out anymore
because what you're doing I'm against
Disney loses 78 000 jobs DeSantis keeps
Disney World open the restaurants around
all stay in business they're not
affected by it because people are going
to Disney World and the businesses
around that we're making money when
people were staying at Disney World
staying intact then they interviewed the
businesses around Disneyland that no
longer got the traffic they got
destroyed Disney has screwed it up so
bad the last 24 36 months if they don't
get their act together hell of course
someone's gonna buy them out uh at a
Pennies on a dollar and some Scott
Rodriguez was a valetaner he's a PPD
podcaster a member uh he just gave a
Super Chat 50 bucks and he said I was
just at Disney World November 11 till
the 20th with the family this was the
sixth time going on in the last 10 years
pbd we are a Disney family I can tell
you the magic is gone and it's so sad
Apple buying Disney will ruin Disney
apple is so woke anyway so Apple's even
woker than Disney oh yeah he's saying
Apple easy can I ask you a question
because you've got four kids all
basically ten and under yep uh Kevin
you've got I got three okay how old are
they 17 18 and 21. okay so you've got
teenagers in college age Tom you've got
teenagers yep you know I've got a nephew
who's 10 right and all my buddies all
have kids they're all between five and
12 years old I don't have kids
um but is it is that the common
denominator it's just like listen I
don't think anybody cares what you do in
your private life you want to be gay you
want to be trans like go for it yeah I
mean I'm from Florida my sister went to
UCF she worked at Disney all her friends
were gay they're all the musical theater
kids that go to I work a lot I don't
work a lot of gay apps literally nobody
has a problem with them but I mean I'm
speaking as as not a parent I'm more
asking you guys is that where you draw
the line obviously it's like look do
what you guys want to do we really don't
care but when you start trying to
indoctrinate six-year-olds 10 year olds
12 year olds that's where we have our
problems I say let people grow up and
find out where they want to be in their
life when they grow up why there's
forcing on them when they're five six
years old what the Santas did was saying
this is ridiculous to do these to kids
that don't say gay let them figure out
if they're great and under I went
through high school and there when I
went to class reunions five and ten
years later and then like five or six of
the guys that I had no idea Were Gay
we're gay now and I said did you have to
hide this during high school did you
know back then a couple of them said
yeah but I didn't know that yeah I
couldn't have cared less if they were or
not but it was interesting that they had
to hide it and I think that's their
biggest battles we need to not be afraid
to come out we'll find to come out in
today's world I don't think anybody's
afraid anymore especially in America you
know just go go for it which is fine but
I think people are tired of being forced
on their throats constantly it's
constant going on it's like every
commercial every it's like fine
congratulations you know I mean it's
it's just it's gotten to a point now
that people just I just fed up with it
and I think people are getting more
vocal about it now order your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody